bonsoir Monsieur aimant soit monsieur
Fillon alors résultat négatif vous avez
insisté beaucoup aujourd'hui pour dire
que quand on se compare aux autres aux
autres portefeuilles quand même la
caisse sentir assez bien mais ça nous
prend au tripes à chaque fois qu'on voit
un résultat négatif à la Caisse de dépôt
est-ce que vous auriez pu après coup
faire mieux écouter trois choses je
pense qu'ils sont importantes vous avez
raison c'est des gros chiffres là on
minimise pas ça mais trois choses telles
pires semestre en 50 ans pour les
marchés dans lequel on a opéré on a
mieux fait dans cet environnement le
marché boursier obligataire ont baissé
entre 10 et
30%, ne fait moins 7.9% on va aussi
notre indice de référence le
portefeuille de référence auquel on se
compare qui est à -10.5% qui est
exigeant premier point
plus important encore pour moi c'est
pour illustrer un peu qu'on est dans une
succession de conditions extrêmes depuis
deux ans et ça va perdurer meilleur
exemple
et six mois qu'on vient de rapporter au
30 juin notre portefeuille je prends des
chiffres là en baissant en valeur de 30
milliards depuis le 30 juin en moins
d'un mois on a récupéré la moitié 15
milliards les thés a été bon sur les
marchés alors ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que c'est des conditions aux
extrêmes qu'on vit alors moi comme tu es
DG quand je vais me demander ce que le
portefeuille va bien la question pour
les déposants pour notre conseil
d'administration ce qu'on est dans une
crise un peu depuis deux ans pendant
cette période là le portefeuille de la
Caisse a rapporté 7.3% par année deux
fois plus que notre indice de référence
qui est à 3.6%. et ça c'est une
performance record dans l'histoire de la
caisse et des actifs font monter de 60
milliards donc de ce contexte je me dis
donc stratégies fonctionnent donc vos
stratégies fonctionnent et ça ne vous
inquiète pas comme situation c'est une
situation
qui nous rend extrêmement vigilants
parce qu'elle est fait quand même de
montagnes russes faut les appeler dans
ces marchés là on en a encore pour un
bout de temps six mois 12 mois
facilement on est construit de passer à
travers ça mais néanmoins ça va être un
environnement difficile encore pour un
bout de temps que le temps que
l'économie retrouve cet équilibre les
banques centrales face à terre les taux
sans trop créer de récession de
ralentissement économique de ramener
l'inflation des niveaux tolérables vous
aviez annoncé votre sortie de
l'extraction du pétrole et du gaz ça se
passait cette année cette sortie là
est-ce que vous ratez le rebond
pétrolier faut toujours voir l'autre
patte de la transaction comme je dis au
niveau de la de ce que vous mentionnez
c'est vrai qu'on avait commencé à sortir
depuis 2018 du pétrole on a terminé en
2022 et en 2022 je tiens à dire aux gens
on a vendu toutes nos positions à Fort
profit parce que le prix du pétrole est
à 90 ans la question c'est ce qu'on
aurait pu en faire plus en restant
jusqu'à la fin il faut toujours voir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on vend et
une autre picatrain si vous regardez les
marchés boursiers ont baissés dans notre
allocation d'actifs ont été là en
infrastructure on investit dans le
renouvelable on a fait 6 milliards de
profits pendant cette période-là
deux milliards de profits dans le gaz
naturel alors est-ce que ça compense
complètement le type de cette fois ce
que vous ne gagnez plus dans le pétrole
au niveau climatique pour la pour la
pour la planète alors moi ce que je dis
on doit avoir une obligation de
rendement pour nous déposants on se met
la barre haute pour faire la bonne chose
d'un point de vue climatique puis la
preuve est là les crypto-monnaies je
pense que ça retient beaucoup notre
attention et cette plateforme de crypto
monnaie c'est juste network dans lequel
vous avez injecté 200 millions de
dollars vous l'avez fait un moment où il
y avait déjà des questions qui se
posaient sur celle-ci se network
aujourd'hui vous êtes obligé de radier
cet investissement là vous dites que
vous êtes pas très fier de ce qui s'est
passé par rapport à ça est-ce que vous
admettez des erreurs dans ce dossier là
ça va être un investisseur c'est un
processus interactif on apprend tout le
temps qui est important c'est comprendre
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé pour répéter
même erreurs en jamais faire qui sont
fatales dans le code Celsius vous avez
raison premièrement la personne est
content à la caisse de tout ça moi le
premier on en fait un post mortem
important mais il faut quand même le
mettre en perspective c'est une
exception dans notre portefeuille de
capital de risque pourquoi c'est un
portefeuille qui est performant c'est un
portefeuille qu'on fait de façon plus
prudente que l'industrie 35% de
rendement par année depuis 5 ans puis le
tout le taux de perte dans l'industrie
en capital de risque c'est 45%. nous il
est de 10%. on est rentré un peu tôt la
situation de l'entreprise elle avait mis
père croissance à gérer c'est fragilisé
est-ce que vous auriez pas dû ne pas
entrer du tout parce qu'au moment où
vous entrez il y a déjà des questions
sur la gestion de celles-cius Network
qui se pose à ce moment-là est-ce que ça
a été une erreur mais une erreur quand
on en investissement que ce soit Celsius
n'importe quel puis qu'on aurait dit à
Sion
c'est une erreur le monsieur Fillion
est-ce que je voudrais dire c'est la
chose suivante évidemment c'est risque
là sont identifiés mais le capital de
risque implique de transformer une
société on a des discussions avec les
agences réglementaires on avait
l'intention de d'aider réglementer le
secteur à le transformer a aussi capturé
le potentiel la technologie blockchain
et on n'est pas le seul investisseur qui
est là dedans Black Rock la semaine
dernière investi dans les
crypto-monnaies les plus grandes banques
sont dedans alors on apprend de ça et
puis non plus la conclusion n'est pas
encore arrivée dans cette histoire-là on
va regarder aussi comme je l'ai dit nos
options légales donc les devant les
tribunaux pour récupérer je peux pas
dire tout ce qu'on va regarder ses
options là on verra ça dépendra des
circonstances il y a encore beaucoup à
faire dans ce processus de
restructuration se peut-il que la caisse
n'avait pas nécessairement l'expertise
nécessaire pour investir dans ce type
d'investissement crypto monnaie
plateforme de crypto monnaie chaîne de
bloc écouter c'est pas comme si on avait
décidé du jour au lendemain de se lancer
dans soit il y a tout un secteur de
nouvelles économie avec des experts qui
suivent ça depuis deux trois ans on a
regardé cette entreprise là on avait des
experts aussi de l'externe qu'on prend
des consultants qui nous accompagnent de
faire une réputée dans un processus
comme ça alors moi j'ai la compréhension
qu'on avait une bonne saisie des enjeux
et parfois ce qui arrive tu peux
identifier bien les risques tu peux
faire la bonne vérification diligente
mais tu vas me manquer de temps les
défis sont là que les identifies ils
prennent plus de temps on sous-estime le
temps requis les efforts requis pour la
réglementation ont arrivés trop tôt et
des événements aussi exogène la crise
est arrivée on avait amené une nouvelle
direction le numéro 2 de la Banque
Royale c'est quand même pas n'importe
qui qui avait un plan très clair mais
elle manquait de temps avec cette crise
là est-ce que vous évaluez la
possibilité à combien vous évaluez la
possibilité d'une récession présentement
écoutez on dirait que c'est probablement
aux environs de peut-être 50% 40 à 50% à
quel endroit ça dans le monde entier je
veux dire c'est différent parce que
personne n'est au même endroit la Chine
à ses enjeux le rap et ses enjeux
l'Amérique du Nord si on prend
l'Amérique du Nord on va peut-être plus
un ralentissement économique pour faire
attention avant de tomber dans récession
il reste encore beaucoup d'inconnus avec
les banques centrales et des données de
contradictoires nouveau économiques on
voit le PIB qui descend on voit le
marché de l'emploi qui est encore solide
le Canada pourrait être un frapper un
peu plus fort que les États-Unis mais le
Québec ferait mieux dans le Canada
j'avais un résumer un peu et
fondamentaux au Québec sont solides le
taux d'épargne est plus élevé dans le
reste du Canada le tournant
d'endettement est moindre niveau
résidentiel les maisons c'est plus
proche des fondamentaux comme valeur
donc le Québec est bien placé une bonne
économie c'est juste que vivre sur une
île complètement isolée c'est
probablement présomptu de croire qu'on
va être complètement sauvegarder tout ça
et le risque au Québec vous l'évaluer à
combien
dans les mêmes jours à peu près un tiers
40%, on verra mais je pense qu'on est
capable de se distinguer dans cet
environnement-là on est un des endroits
qui a quand même des bonnes assises pour
faire face à ce qui s'en vient ok on est
habitué de parler du rêve à chaque fois
qu'on se voit on va en parler un peu
brièvement cependant dépassement de
cours retard pour l'entrée en service du
REM il y aura des informations qui vont
venir vous prévoyez faire le point sur
cette question là et puis sortie du
règne de l'Est ça c'était au mois de mai
est-ce que est-ce que tout ça refroidit
vos ardeurs dans le développement de ce
type de projet
[Musique]
du coup merci Monsieur et moi d'avoir le
plaisir merci Monsieur pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI